what we're going to do is we're going to
do a communal bot to let the goats know
we're ready and make them feel
something's happening to my back pharah
one of them's fighting me you're gonna
take a deep breath in
and exhale with a big long
I think you guys can do better than that
let's try again inhale I was distracted
oh they're killing Luke
they will be interacting with you in
ways you may not expect they have no
boundaries okay be ready for anything
really they don't they're not shy about
the back stuff no I'm glad we got those
gloves on the Hooves uh that well I'd
certainly feel some pressure on the
stretch
that's go yoga benefit number two
oh boy sometimes it does feel a little I
think they're coming at you